you
hi everyone is Gerry I'm on leeches org
and I'm playing a 15-2 game let's try
you far I've been playing Knight f3
maybe too much it's been a while since I
played a standard game against a human
so a Sicilian I really enjoy standard
play what about you feel free to share
in the comments this is a really good
time control to improve your game not
too long not too short
uh-huh okay
I've had this played against me before
let's go with let's go at c3 and we'll
see what happens okay so I've had Knight
f6 before this was my idea to take and
then strike at their pawn duo which they
don't have okay so they're recapturing
with the Queen hmm well I don't have
Knight c3 with tempo I'm considering
Knight a 3 d 4 and that's pretty much it
Knight a three with Knight b5 in mind or
maybe even some combination of Bishop c4
hmm I wonder what the
differences are is this really such an
inconvenience to black hmm might be I
mean on night a3 playing a6 to guard b5
it does weaken b6 so maybe a later night
c4 can prove useful now let's give it a
shot I'm not fearful any Queen check
before I just block so I'm tryin Itay
three this isn't well I'll still be
playing d4 and I will manage that but I
want to mix it up a little bit trying
Knight a 3-1 line I believe is d4 and on
takes not to recapture immediately but
instead play Knight b5 so even on knight
c6 I could play d4 I have enough defense
for it and I don't necessarily have to
eventually recapture with a pond I could
play within well I could maybe
transition to a structure where I have a
majority on the Queen side of three
versus two okay so they do opt for a six
hmm the weakness behind that move is b6
can I take advantage of that I must say
Knight c4 right away seems appealing if
black has to defend b6 with the night
then isn't that a little bit awkward for
the bishop well maybe not so much
actually because we could be pretty sure
b5 will occur to deploy the bishop the
bishop really wouldn't want to make use
of this square anyway so I'm not quite
sure if I want to play Knight c4 right
away
I think 90 97 is fine on the other side
of the coin mm-hm
let's see I mean I could play d4 I was a
little bit hesitant to play d4 because
Bishop takes Knight but I always have
Queen a4 and then the recapture I have
two pieces out they just have their
Queen developed I don't know how great a
piece the knight is on a three mm-hm
play to see to to defend d4 if I wanted
to about huh you know I think you like
this Bishop c4 eventually I mean it like
gains a tempo for the moment but later
backfires with b5 so don't know that
it's really such a good idea to do that
hmm
what am i considering here d4 hmm Oh
actually how about this maybe maybe I
could consider Knight c4 997 I insert
them of a4 and then threatening a5 I
think on Knight c4 Knight d7 Knight c4
Knight d7 a4 b6 would be played just to
stop at this clamping down move a5 and
at that point maybe then I could play d4
and now that I have my knight stabilized
and c4 I'm gonna give that a shot yeah
let's go for them okay let's see what
comes up with this was the only move I
was considering is there something else
ah probably not a good idea to devote
the Queen to defending a square with
Queen c6 restricting the Queen like that
probably not such a good idea so how to
defend against a knight that's throwing
an attack ideally I think some pawn
would like to have that role it's not
available for black to devote upon to
defend b6 but that's kind of the natural
progression the Knights causing you an
issue ideally you'd like to have
something of lesser value deal with that
piece not the case here black will have
to develop something more so a knight
will combat a knight I think for this b6
square so that they kind of balance out
is this a worthwhile tempo I think it is
I do not want to get pushed around
playing b5 allowing this fork and then
playing Queen Checketts it's a fork of
more than just the Queen and rook I'm
hitting the bishop as well so you just
can't allow the night to get to b6
altogether we're surprised that black is
spending so much time here I guess the
other move that's being considered is
Queen to d8 now this would be very
awkward for the knight on c6 so maybe
she's considering going all the way back
home but that seems a little bit slow
I'd uh I'd certainly welcome that move
yeah if you want to run home under
develop in 97 I'm pretty much locked
into a for I do not want to get kicked
around or mm-hm
maybe I could actually just play the
strike in the center what's d4 now I'm
going to be consistent here let's
maintain my knight position so I'm
expecting b6 I think if that's a super
important move if I get a 5 in that
really locks down on their Queen side
completely the knight can't move the
rook
move the bishop can't move already
necessity is v6 I think so I mean you
have to do this eventually anyhow to get
the bishop to b7 so I'm expecting b6 I
did one other thing I did consider I
I've been talking about a four but I did
consider instead of a four D for right
away and on b5 I was only later
realizing I have a counter-attacking
night to e3 basically getting the move
back and then maybe I could look for the
a4 move to try and rip open the position
at a moment where I have a time
advantage not a clock advantage time
position wise on the board okay so
they're doing nothing about this
clamping down move I think that that's a
mistake
hmm well this is a very huge positional
Trump and I think it is time well spent
without question also I wonder if I
should really go forward with d4
I mean I'm I'm a bit tempted to maybe
keep the structure as is not allow any
let's say not allow the exchange for the
Dean the D the D and E pond or excuse me
the D and C pawn exchange as this would
allow some new possibilities for the
bishop or Knight maybe uncie five I
don't know that I want to recapture with
the pawn I know this is a pretty tame
decision to have the pawn on d3 instead
of d4 but I really like the clamping
effect that I have with this night on c4
and on an 85 this is one of those
instances where in my eyes at least I I
see this group of two pawns and I it's
it's just like the one pond is
controlling too
and they're backward I've control over
v6 so what would black do here Bishop to
e7 um for a moment I thought about doing
this but I already have one door open
for my Bishop is this time well spent to
open up another one and get on the main
diagonal I don't think so
I should probably play Bishop e2 Castle
mm-hmm we'll see what black does in the
meantime I do have this move I should
keep this in mind not only the forward
move with an attack against the queen
but whoa all right so placing the bishop
right in a position where I could take
it hmm I think maybe I should probably
this actually yeah I should look to open
up the position I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna put my pawn on d3 what's so wrong
about d4 in fact now that my knight has
pressure on the bishop mm-hmm if I open
up the position if I threaten a queen
trade I'm threatening more than that
trying to take that bishop this night is
still monster with or without Queens d4
seems right don't know that I'm
threatening to take just yet you know
here's another way to view it if I don't
play d4 right now
Mike black establish a pond in the
center with e5 and I lose this
opportunity altogether
I want to play this position where I
maintain this clamp on the queenside and
I really don't want to allow black - hmm
I don't want to give them anything in
the form of let's say a space advantage
if I'm having to play against C v e5
structure and my pond sits on d3 there's
a slight space disadvantage for white so
I don't want to give block that so I'm
pretty much zoning in on this d4 move on
just double-checking
this Queen check is of no bother I
develop and defend defend develop and
block let's go with d4 with this bishop
underdeveloped the stability of my
pieces in particular on these light
squares it's nice to have that security
I'm never fearful of some pin or even
this pressure against my knight the
bishops not going to cause my Knights an
issue so it's really only the the Black
Knights that can challenge my Knights
the knight on c4 he must be a great
great bother my dark square bishop I'm
not quite sure where he belongs so there
may be some lag with his development all
right so what I'm getting at is I would
I would pretty much do bishop move
castle and then think about what in the
world to do with him
maybe I still wouldn't even know so
recapture with the Knight Queen I really
want to stay clear of the of the
pon capture yeah let's see let's take
with the Queen what's wrong with that so
we're gonna go into hmm how do we define
it and it doesn't really matter what we
call it an endgame or a queen this
middle game
pick your favorite so let's see I'm
threatening to win just taking the
bishop
we are pretty even timewise clockwise so
let us see yeah I think you have to take
my queen though on Queen takes I'm going
to take with my knight maybe they're
considering a bishop move this is uh a
way to cover the b6 square there might
be some role reversal have the bishop
responsible for this or the knight could
finally move okay uh-huh
interesting moment if I take the Queen
the pond takes and then my knight has to
find a new home don't know that I want
to allow my knight to be kicked so
easily
can i play Queen to h4 Queen h4 this
night might play over here but maybe
that's ok I may want to keep the Queen's
on the board because another way to view
this is you need to keep in mind that
the D file is completely open so if I
get a couple quick developing moves in
having the Queen's avoiding the Queen
exchange I could eventually grab a tempo
against the Queen so that would be
really nice lacks one move away from
being castled Queen h4 castle Bishop e2
I'm just one move away I don't think
that that should be a problem on Queen
h4 in some idea of a knight transfer to
g6 I could always meet that move with
Queen g5 I don't need my Queen here to
defend my knight my bishop has that
responsibility f2 is maybe a little bit
soft after my Queen moves is that an
exploitable point it's happy it's
attacked once defended once I think I
like having my Queen still on the board
I really it's coming down to I want to
maintain my knight on c4 I could look to
play against the isolated pawn on Queen
takes pawn takes but I don't like that
it kicks my knight and opens the door
for the light square bishop on the other
hand if I move my queen maybe b5 will be
played you know they have enough
coverage for this mmm maybe in the end I
do end up just exchanging Queens let's
consider hmm I could do Queen takes
that's tricky too Queen takes pawn takes
my knight is hit to play Knight here
yeah I could do that night here and then
to c2 yeah maybe I will in the end play
against the isolated pawn yeah on Queen
h4 I think b5 and then you know the
Knights recapture
they're getting rid of my night from
there I don't know what kind of an
advantage I would have so maybe it's
time to cash out a little bit
in exchange Queens and look to play
against an isolated pawn because I
really am expecting pawn takes let's
let's go for that the Queens they're
gone how to recapture I'm expecting this
to remove this pesky Knight and we will
see if this advance does get played a 6
is a bit tender bit soft some pressure
would come immediately against it by
both Brooke the bishop already but the
rook comes to life with the b-pawn
advance so it's a thinker for sure
maintain the structure or not we're
going to see
if Knight takes where do I go with my
bishop probably eat to keeping him off
of this open file for when a rook does
play to the open file I want hit it to
have clear sight aha
so the structures maintained let me be
quick with this move
keep him recognized the types of files
on the board open half open closed
Bishop's tend to function better on well
half open files for white or just closed
files and I can't do without castling
let's get castle so still I don't know
where he belongs
I certainly want to keep him around to
watch over the f4 square and how to
untangle the the situation on the Queen
side for black still remains they have a
problem that they need to solve which is
how to complete Queen side development
how to get their Queen Bishop out for me
on well I'm one move away but yeah I
still I still don't know where he
belongs I'd probably invest in move like
well I deploy my rook to the D file
don't know there is a structure wise on
the Queen side I do have an advantage
it's a healthy three versus two majority
and the King side black has a majority
so these might be ideas to implement for
both sides to start pushing the pawns
but I could still work on getting
getting my all of my pieces mobilized
and you have to watch out the e pawn and
the F pawn may start to push so let's
see
hmm what is the weakness behind that
last move e5 is now given up blacks
trying to do this if I could grab the
bishop pair at least I'm playing still
it's something here well it still is
something you know there still is an
invalid there's an imbalance in the
position regarding the structure but if
I could also grab the bishop pair I
think that would be nice
so let's improve this Knight yeah who's
gonna argue with that move strong
position in the center a new possibility
maybe even for the bishop don't know
that he's needed anymore to watch over
the knight is he I have some good
coordination between these guys you know
I still don't know where he belongs
am i tactically vulnerable at all I
don't think so I mean I have one
unprotected piece black has an
unprotected piece I'm not really seeing
a way to take advantage of these things
for either side hmm
under five for both of us only 14 moves
in playing with yeah okay two second
increments okay well what is black going
to do if they play Bishop d7 I'm gonna
gonna snip that Bishop what kind of
exchanges and I welcome to is maybe a
question to ask I think having this dark
square bishop exchanged the dark square
Bishop sixth angel if we imagine this
position without the dark square Bishop
there's some fixed pawns here that are
in good harmony with my resulting Bishop
and therefore these guys are one-day
potential targets for my e to Bishop
black can
say the same if the dark square bishop
are exchanged he doesn't really have any
great targets now this rook is
unprotected let's get to this file f2 is
vulnerable hang on
f2 is vulnerable huh maybe it is
important I first moved my bishop here
if I'm a bit fearful of 94 if I play rip
d1 glad I caught that f2 is vulnerable
this Knight is restricted maybe I should
first restrict this Knight
let's do it Bishop f3 it's an
improvement of a piece that's it's an
improvement to a piece that's already
developed he still needs to play but I
needed to be a bit careful I think 94
would have been a fine reply although
this Knight is in a pin the rook is
unprotected and such I need to guard e4
I think at least this also makes life
difficult to get a b5 move in I don't
think that that's ever going to happen
but we'll see I mean I think black has
to play here or maybe challenge the
knight with 97 but I have a backup here
there's two knights that you basically
have to address on the e5 square this
still might be an idea though okay
offering the up the bishop pair 97 with
maybe f6 to control the square might
have been an idea so I think I can take
and yeah I probably should take so I
have 95 with tempo the bishop pair you
know what I can consider 95 actually
within c4r though I am giving up the B
Foursquare rook d1 is natural and
probably fine
don't know where my dark square bishop
belongs maybe something simple like rook
d1 King f1 King e1 is fine um no
trickiness my rook is protected on d1
also on did the doubling of rooks I
could still play King f1 without fear of
Knight here because I recapture and then
have a second defender of d1 yeah this
is this fish opposed it he's a really
good piece in fact he's the unopposed
bishop
he's uh he's the tough guy he's
definitely the tough guy in the position
yes always keeping a watchful eye on b7
even if it is indirect this place is a
certain restriction on blacks pieces in
a great way not only is the knight
controlled but the knight is pinned so I
may follow up with something simple and
try to be a bit practical here keeping a
watchful eye on the time applying some
quick moves this may come down to a
little bit of a mouse race but what's
most important is still to play good
moves not be the the time burning
strategies don't work with the increment
so on the doubling of rooks I'm really
locked in I think to King and f1 I don't
see any great Knight move that would
hurt me uh-huh that can't be too fun to
move to play hmm King improvement yeah
let's go Oh another thing was that on
this night move I even have a knight
recapture to defend if there was the
doubling the D file so I would imagine
they're they're prepping b5 but my rook
is going to be pretty excited about that
idea I think they would just lose upon
know if b5 is the idea we're going to
see
I could even think about creeping a one
step closer
that's so sure I'm king eat okay so
they're just making useful movies g5a
problem um let me just insert this move
make a quick move if this was their idea
to expand a little bit and question the
positioning of my bishop just take that
out of the equation right away
try stay ahead on the clock here I'm not
usually very good with doing that but uh
I think that's a fine reply h6
I'm meeting h6 with h4 so black is uh
back on movin so they're in a tough spot
with trying to find ways to improve the
position of their pieces if there's ever
the exchange of rooks black is having to
of course recapture but retreat when
they recapture so one of their pieces is
essentially demoted for a move mm some
serious time pressure here I hope it
doesn't turn out to be a loss on time I
want this game to finish I don't want it
to be a time when okay so they're
dropping the bishop all the way back
uh-huh so my knight this is the first
moment where I'm seeing that my knight
is maybe not so stable there one move
away from putting direct pressure on my
knight now you know what I could
consider you know I could maybe consider
some some aggressive stuff actually you
know initially in my thought with h4 was
to stop g5 but who's to say that I
cannot consider forming upon duo
and questioning the stability of the
knight on f6 that would really rattle
the black position on a move that
threatens my knight I think 95 is
perfectly fine let's do this i weakened
pretty good amount of squares with this
move f3 f4 but uh-huh okay
let's see I could play here and attack
the rook let's do that I don't think I'm
missing any tricks till I have the stuff
defended so all right g5 and even g6
this Jeep on could turn out to be a
great monster huh big monster okay and
also with g5 you know I'm softening up
the d5 square so this advance may
ultimately allow me to saddle black with
an isolated deep on but it's starting
it's starting to feel like there should
be more let's stay ahead on the clock
let's be consistent pretty much want to
take with the pawn yeah and I d7 just
exchanged nice this is a weak point on
b3 so I mean we have to be a bit careful
of that that seems like a very passive
move and g6 I do have the bishop pair
and pretty welcome to more pawn
exchanges it seems so right let's do it
maybe drop my knight in to f7 he must be
a pretty great bother now huh
this King I'm looking for mating nuts
now let's do that yeah actually
kingi to rock h1 um I'm gonna do this 96
might be played we're both playing off
the increment move ah man they lost on
time hmm oh well what can you do
yeah just when it was really heating up
to 96 certainly I think at least you
have to go with Knight to d6 to
challenge that night because this idea
for me okay maybe the king could run
here but that's a little bit I don't
know maybe this in the end is still
winning it's a time win but what we'll
see hey let me actually just click on
the I'm not the analysis board but
rather um what am I trying to do here
let me let me just go back into my
profile and bring this game up I want to
get a computer evaluation oh I was in
the correct spot there's already huh
there's already an evaluation this is
different just give me a moment I'll
figure this out local computer
evaluation for a variation analysis beta
what happens if I click on that oh this
is different
moves it's gonna change the evaluation
oh it's not aware of this okay maybe we
could just fool around with this then
okay Oh
so it just populates it as you go
through it oh that's different
I wasn't I wasn't aware of this okay so
let's see where we are standing and this
is uh what's this little meter that the
red that's where it's a zero so the more
that it's above that red line is uh the
more of this lighter color you see is
more favorable for white and the other
way is for black so let's see if we are
always staying above that red line hmm
let's see
you know let's get to this uh middle
game position it's having me with the
slight edge right around here it's
maintained even with the Queen's off but
nothing nothing winning okay ah okay so
now it uh it did do the analysis just uh
flicked up there so we'll get to see
some stuff here so this is the first
suggestion coming up H for ya
you know I wonder I'm thinking to myself
you know why during the game when I
played h4 why did I only see that as a
defensive move I'm just I don't know
it's
I I wonder if I could have had a
different frame of mind and saw this as
the only only later did I see it as as
their how to say only later did I see
that h4 could have been one step in the
direction of this aggressive intention
to form that pond duo and disrupt the
coordination of the night's playing with
the bishop pair you really want to make
sure that the Knights don't have good
squares I mean right now this is a
wonderful square on d5 not a hole or
anything at some point it can be kicked
but there is night before my what I'm
trying to trial reference to and
probably too many words is it's usually
a good idea to be disruptive to the
Knights position if you if you're having
the bishop heritage to kick them off the
the posts that they may have there
aren't really any holes in the center so
yeah the site this idea of h4 and then
g4 I think was a good one
yeah after Bishop a7 it likes it likes
me buy something that's now starting to
be pretty significant upon plus instead
of Bishop a7 it considers rook c7 with
the idea to maybe capture and then take
the knight
uh-huh also getting out of the line of
fire here let's still follow this
computer line rook c7 okay for to defend
and okay
finally my dark square bishop comes out
I'm still playing with the bishop pair
though hmm what an interesting line yeah
sure okay
um well that's weird that's the
suggestion and then at the end of the
suggestion it has it with a higher
evaluation then what Bishop a a7 is
reading as okay okay we had g4 on board
not quite upon advantage just yet but
I'll be curious about the final position
was at winning 98 I thought 97 was
necessary yeah 97 to challenge this
piece he's a great bother 97 this is the
computer line 94 you know I didn't I
didn't get to reference this I thought
of this rule but I just to maintain the
just to maintain pieces on the board I
didn't want to be so quick to exchange
I saw the capture as helping the rook
but I didn't go any further it was just
a quick thought I had I didn't share it
this Knight g4 idea I have no I no
particular let's say variation in mind
with the knight being on g4 but yeah
this color scheme gambit let's just
close out of that for now
anyhow yeah Knight g4 just I thought
about it I didn't share my main thought
behind it was to simply not help my
opponent by capturing that helped them
to improve one of their pieces and
maintain a piece on the board but I have
no specific variation in mind I had no
specific variation in mind with the
Knight g4 move this is still the
computer line okay oh that's interesting
you know there is an opportunity to take
the bishop and but at the end he's a
monster mm-hmm you could damage the
structure but then you're having to
devote of rook to defending the pawn and
that's not a good idea because these
rooks once there's tension between them
you know
that's gonna be a problem can't you
can't contest the file and defend the b7
pawn bishop there this is still a
computer line now I'm playing with uh
two bishops who and it's going in for
this variation gobbling up three pawns
for the minor piece oh okay well in the
game at 97 was played oops sorry about
that 97 was played and g6 he had still
holding an advantage close to +2 now
instead of f6 it liked an immediate
Knight to d6 and that's maybe tough to
do but you know cuz I'm gonna split
these guys up another way to view it is
if you let this pawn live he's a
tremendous thorn and mating ideas with a
knight on f7 or even even one day some
possibilities of Bishop h6 just
attacking here and if he's captured I'm
two steps away he's a he's a great thorn
this is this a five pawn started out in
the middle game to be a thorn he
remained a thorn restricted in Queen
side but allowing of Han on g6 upon with
such great depth yeah f6 two-point
advantage Knight f7 rook d7 +2 hmm I
played king g2 which wasn't the best
yeah it's still upon and a half
advantage I'm not quite sure how things
would have finished up here I would have
I would have liked to have seen but yeah
I mean I do have these ideas coming in
for me I was expecting Knight d7 ooh
yeah that's neat so we could test out
and see where the evaluation is like d6
and then what would happen just takes
here now it doesn't like that
it's telling me it has the arrow here
pay attention these arrows they mean
something here uh-huh
Bishop takes 90 and then if Knight takes
Knight
yikes were up to nearly plus six because
of that rook takes rook pawn takes and
then takes here Oh
so Knight takes rook would have to take
and then hmm okay I guess I really don't
have anything in this direction
I don't have the night here coordinating
on h8 I want to play rook a3 with this
idea and I mean I'm still playing with
an advantage the bishop pair and more
active pieces the rook bishop both rooks
and bishop are playing I'm not sure
about either sides dark square bishop in
this position I mean he's it's weird
this is one of those I don't know rare
cases but it's a bishop on c8 who hasn't
moved but in a way he kind of is
developed only want to move him to get
the a rook doing something about this
this is a satisfactory way a fine way it
appears at least to activate the rook by
way of a three Oryx c7 no that starts to
be a little bit mysterious to me it's
suggesting rook a four what's wrong to
be three okay yeah I don't know that's a
interesting game and cool tool here I
just uh this is news to me I was not
aware of this but uh yeah I like being
able to check out with the evaluation
like that yeah interesting game
hopefully I I think I shared a lot of
things in the early stage and I hope as
usual
and this was helpful to you I really do
enjoy the standard time control games or
a lot and my suggestion to you is if
you're looking to improve your games
certainly give these this time control
shot really devote some time and I think
it's uh I think it's a good one not too
not too long as mentioned not too long
not too short of time control and get
some good games in some nice quality
games and also I want to play with
increment to avoid the situations where
your opponent tries to time burn and
helps out with the quality of the game
but uh yeah interesting game as usual I
hope you got something out of it and
feel free to leave any feedback in the
comments section below so that's all for
now take care bye
you